the United States military's had a lot
of experience in the western Pacific
taking down small islands I'm not so
veiled warning to China to halt its
military buildup on contested islands in
the South China Sea satellite photos
show China has placed new surface-to-air
missiles in the Spratlys and recently
landed nuclear capable bombers on woody
island China calls the accusations
ridiculous defense secretary Jim mattis
will reassure allies the US will not
allow China to spread its influence
unchecked there had been a promise in
2015 by the president Shaye where he
stated they would not be militarized in
the Spratly Islands we have seen the
last month they have done exactly that
at a change of command ceremony in
Hawaii the outgoing head of US Pacific
forces Admiral Harry Harris a China Hawk
issued another warning China remains our
biggest long-term challenge without
focused involvement and engagement by
the United States and our allies and
partners China will realize its dream of
hegemony in Asia we should cooperate
with Beijing where we can but stand
ready to confront them what we must the
u.s. has stepped up operations to
counter China sending naval vessels near
those contested man-made islands this
past weekend and Madison ounce T is
changing the name of US Pacific Command
or PACOM to Indo PACOM a shot across the
bow at China which feels threatened by
rival India the latest US military move
serves as a backdrop to potential North
Korea talks our 27 year holiday from
history is over great power competition
is bad Admiral Harris is slated to be
President Trump's next ambassador to
South Korea